what's Keanu Reeves like in real life he
is very soft-spoken he's a very good
listener very good student we didn't
really trade too many stories or
anything he just came out to train and I
kept it extremely professional honestly
he's one of the best students or people
that I've ever trained he just really
picks up on things what makes a very
good student of somebody that wants to
learn about protection
aggression Precision takes a good
listener in that industry you get a lot
of people that come out they like to say
that since they were five or they've
been hunting since they were walking and
they always have these stories and it's
this is how I do it this is how I've
always done it but when you get a guy
like Keanu or a lot of women are like
this too they're like a sponge they
listen they retain the information all
they're worried about is what you're
saying doing it what you're doing and
that's what makes a good student you
don't need to be an athlete you don't
need to be super intelligent or anything
like that you just need to be able to
listen